my mother had a really bad childhood and
my father had a bad childhood and I had
about two other but I love my childhood
even though it was bad I love it I feel
like it's taught me so much
and I feel like nothing can faze me you
know nothing in his world nothing can
surprise me it might set me back but
only momentarily only to spring back and
I think it's helped me um to learn it
really did help me learn and since my
mother had a bad childhood
she knows the importance of being honest
and the importance of facing each
situation as it comes and not dealing in
fairytale land being realistic about the
problem and analyzing it and solving it
see what you can do to solve it so if
you have a happy childhood you tend to
want your child to have a happy
childhood so you tend to want to keep
the bad things out and I don't think
that's good because you don't prepare
for the world all be SSI it all comes
down to we got to survive I mean even
warriors put their spirits down on
Sundays we got to survive here in this
country cuz I'm not going back to Africa
we got to survive here for us to survive
here white folks black folks Korean
folks Mexican folks Puerto Ricans we got
to understand each other you gotta take
take a bigger chance and when I say
Americans people think I'm talking about
Uncle Sam I mean you you you I mean you
need to do something you just watch -
amazing clips of Tupac Shakur take the
next three minutes to sit quietly and
think about how you can apply them to
your business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you